good evening and welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan on Sunset from
here the governor's mansion in
Tallahassee Florida this is the home of
Florida's governor Ron DeSantis the man
and many things could be the next
president of the United States Miranda
Santos will soon deliver his State of
the State address he's set to outline
his agenda and highlight his possible
2024 presidential campaign the Santas
has an even bigger lead more than 20
points in the survey that we showed you
just yesterday the news comes as
DeSantis top Republican rival former
president Trump faces new legal trouble
I just spent more than an hour with the
governor and we covered a wide range of
issues from Ukraine that was a bit
surprised I think some people were that
you seem to be almost dismissing that's
not true a kind of local dispute
they you authorize the use of course
feeding some of the yeah the detainees
who are on Hunger Strike I was a junior
officer I didn't have authority to
authorize anything and in Iraq we could
defeat them on the battlefield without
even blinking an eye Sue how he proposed
to his wife we were out on the balcony
and just kind of dropped to the knee and
you did me oh yeah of course so you took
the knee Governor yeah yeah that's the
only time I take a knee is for that one
really thinks Donald Trump you made a
fatal error in your relationship what's
that Donald Trump you got too popular
of course the burning question everybody
wants to know
what's up is he gonna run you think you
can beat by I think so
you're running them here it is me
one-on-one with Governor Ron DeSantis
the governor's mansion
[Music]
Mr Governor well first of all thank you
very much indeed welcome to the free
state of Florida I've come all the way
from London for this so uh you know
that's because London like most cities
in the world right now and most
countries in the world they're all
beginning to ask the same question who's
this guy Ron DeSantis
are you aware of this I am and uh we've
been able to see a little bit of that
and look I have the privilege of being
the governor of one of the most dynamic
jurisdictions in the world right now if
you look over the last four or five
years the amount of people that have
decided to move uh to Florida just visit
Florida or even just look to Florida for
inspiration has been unlike anything
we've seen in the state's history so
we've got a lot of tremendous people
here we've got a lot going on that's
positive and we're not afraid to lead
the way I want to start with a positive
quote which you're going to really like
and then move on to some negatives that
other people have said so it's going to
start well this okay this is from a guy
called Richard Littlejohn he writes for
the Daily Mail newspaper in the UK also
a Florida resident for many decades and
he's a friend of mine and he wrote this
recently DeSantis is living proof that
when conservatives govern as conviction
conservatives committed to Freedom Light
regulation low taxes strong borders and
proper policing and don't crumble in the
face of militant wokery and mad
environmentalism being imposed by a
noisy minority of head bangers voters
lap it up and he he wrote this obviously
after your thumping one win in the
midterms what's your response to that
first well was that a good
categorization I mean why you think
you've been successful I think oh that's
true
um I think you know you just think of
environment we've done more on
conservation for Everglades but this is
like things that really matter to people
I'm not trying to control their lives
I'm just trying to make the environment
better crime or Law and Order we are not
dealing with letting criminals out or
going soft I actually removed a Soros
back prosecutor from Tampa who said he
wasn't going to follow the law uh covid
we made sure that we protected people's
freedoms people knew they could come
here and do well and yes we have no
income tax we have one of the lowest per
capita tax burdens in the country lowest
per capita debt Burns in the country and
the largest budget surplus in the
history of the state we have more people
significantly more people employed today
than we did pre-covet a lot of the
lockdown States still haven't gotten
back to their pre-covered employment
levels and so I think what we've done is
worked and I think people have responded
positively
all this has made you very popular in
Florida I mean just anecdotally being
here for a few days I've been completely
stunned frankly by the amount of
adulation you get from Floridians almost
everyone I was talking to well we love
the governor we love Ronda Sanders like
Relentless right so that's great but as
your star has risen as you know
out of come the knives out have come The
Wider World wanting to say okay well
this is who this guy is so I want to
read you some of the negatives sure okay
um
this is from Vanity Fair they said
you're a wannabe autocrat already
governed the Sunshine State like a
Banana Republic you're the Genghis Khan
of social issues using every opportunity
to Target and demonize groups that have
already been targeted and demonized
throughout history
um Trevor Noah called you an ignorant
racist
Stephen Colbert a gaping leap
Seth Meyer said you were cruel sadistic
stupid repulsive ghoulish when you see
this kind of feature what it says to me
as a journalist who's covered a lot of
presidential runs and political
maneuverings is the means that people
are getting a bit worried about you I
think that's right I think I think they
see me over the target I'm obviously
coming at it from a different
perspective than they like to see those
are all people on the on the left and
sometimes far left
um but here's the thing I think the
reason why I won the biggest landslide
in the history of Florida for for
Governor's race is because that
criticism is so far removed from the
reality there's legitimate things we can
criticize everybody for including me but
when you start talking about being an
autocrat all I do is I look at my
Constitutional Powers and I govern in a
way to advance the principles that I
believe in I'm passing things through
the legislature that's the
Constitutional way to do business here
they get mad if we sign legislation but
I'm not just doing it alone and I would
note they don't have the same criticism
of Biden if he does unilateral
forgiveness of student loans or some of
these other things so I think a lot of
it's misplaced and I think part of it is
like people look and they say okay
you're saying like all these crazy
things I'm looking at this guy he makes
sense to me the criticism really falls
on deaf ears and I got it from all
quarters for the whole time I was
governor I mean you know during covet I
was the number one Governor being
attacked and that happened pretty much
relentlessly and yet I criticized you
there you go and I discovered that I
checked what I tweeted about you
historically there you go and I found a
tweet I think in 2021 where it looked
like Florida's record was not going to
be good on Covert because you've been
one of the first people in America
certainly to bring back freedoms for
people and I was quite scathing I said
this guy's going to have blood on his
hands actually it didn't turn out that
way actually you were very bold in a lot
of the stuff you were doing Bolder than
many other Governors and it turned out
in in many areas you were Vindicated
well here's the thing excess mortality
lowest in this in the Sun Belt even
lower than New York and California for
all cause excess mortality and then of
course economically in Freedom we've
done way better now listen I was very
concerned about covet because I've got
more elderly than just about anyone I've
got 4 000 long-term care facilities I've
got condos with seniors stuffed in them
all across so this was and I'm a tourism
state so this was a huge existential
threat to Florida so we took it very
soon you want an anti-vaxxer to be clear
right well no look I mean I think that
we we thought the vax would end covet I
think during the Delta wave even though
you had massive vacs you saw a major
wave of covet and so then what I did is
like okay the vax isn't stopping the
spread let's make sure people have
treatments but we took it very seriously
I followed the data but I also believe
that okay there's data that you look at
but you also have to trust people to
make decisions this idea that we're
going to keep using coercion I just
don't think that that works and is
sustainable so part of it was that
science but part of it was also just a
belief in people making their best
decisions for themselves one of the
other criticisms is used against you is
about your personality
it probably comes from people who don't
know you very well because those who do
who I've spoken to tell a different
story but you're being depicted in some
of the national media as very intense
quite boring
um Charisma devoid
you know someone reviewed your book and
said he would launch any charm offensive
unarmed somebody else New York New York
Times a politician's memoir written by
chat GPT right and there's a kind of
consistent vein of this you know you're
aware of this a do you care when people
get personal like this about your
character and B is any of that true or
is it that you have a a kind of a
Persona that you prefer to have as a
leader of a state like Florida and you
save the other stuff from away from the
public glaze well I appreciate the
knocks on the book it's the number one
book in America Far and Away I've sold
more than any non-pre president in the
history of the country in terms of the
first week so we've been doing pretty
good A lot of people like it there's a
hostile New York Times review help sales
yes with conservatives of course it does
yes so here's the thing I think you know
there is these are people who are in the
political class journalist class
politicians and like DC in particular
they get mad I don't do the cocktail
parties I don't like rubbing elbows with
other people I like doing my job and
then spending time with my family that's
just what I do a lot of the people that
are criticizing you know they would say
oh he doesn't do well with with donors
he doesn't glad hand with them and yet I
raise more money than any
non-presidential candidate in the
history of America are you kidding me so
we tend to do we we do well but I do
think that you know I deal better with
regular people than I do with some of
the people in the political class and I
think that has been true for the entire
time I've been been around
your book the best-selling book as you
rightly said uh you start with a quote
from Sir Winston Churchill the greatest
of all britons
um certainly as far as I'm concerned
it's about courage and it says courage
is rightly considered the foremost of
Virtues for upon it all others depend
why did you choose that as the quote to
kind of set up the book because I think
what what I've been called upon to do as
governor is make the right decisions
when it wasn't easy and when people tell
you politically I mean a lot of people
thought I was dead a few years ago
because I was charting my different
course and my view is you know I got
elected to save the jobs of the people I
represent it can't be looking out for my
own job I can't worry about getting
criticized I can't worry about the
political Fallout I've got to do what's
right and I've got to stick by that and
I've got to be willing to take the
arrows and I think we need more of that
in terms of our leaders now because when
you want to do the right thing with the
media environment social media all this
stuff it's usually not like people are
just like oh great like people come at
you and that's just the price you got to
pay for leadership but I think it's a
it's an ingredient That's essential is
Churchill a hero of yours absolutely why
well he saw the danger very very early
on he spoke out uh and he rallied
Britain in a very difficult time and I
think he was just very inspirational
he's a strong leader of course but he
had a way with words I mean how you say
these things to really stir people's
patriotism emotions I think is something
that um that I've always admired courage
is a big theme of your book
what does courage mean to you real
courage
well I think it means just willing to
pay a price and I I tell a story about
when I used to fly to DC you'd fly by
the National Mall look out the left side
of the plane see all the great monuments
and the capitol big man How great is our
country but the best monuments are
really outside the right side of the
plane over the Potomac River in a place
called Arlington National Cemetery
headstones arranged orderly over those
Rolling Hills and and they've made they
made the ultimate sacrifice and it just
shows this is on the grandest level kind
of the best constitution in the world
the best Declaration of Independence in
the world if you don't have people
willing to stand up risk and give their
lives for that it doesn't amount to very
much now here what we have to deal with
is far less than what they had to give
but you do got to give something if
you're not willing to pay a price to
exercise leadership you ain't going to
be a good leader you seem to have a very
thick skin and I mean that as a
compliment yeah
um but even for someone like you as I
say your style Rises and you start being
called the new Hitler the new Mussolini
the new Genghis Khan that's all been
said about you by people I think it
reveals them more than it says anything
about me do you do you care about that
kind of thing no honestly I think if
they have to resort to stuff like that I
mean think about it those names when I'm
the state that's the fastest growing and
the number one net in migration if that
was true people would be fleeing Florida
and I wouldn't have won by 1.5 million
votes so I think it's that they have
trouble really hitting me on substance
and so they got to resort to some of the
knee-jerk stuff so it kind of just
confirmation that I'm over the Target
and look those voices are you know
they're on the far left and they see me
basically beating them on a lot of these
issues there's a great quote and I'm
actually going to say the word although
we'll bleep it when this airs but this
was from a republican consultant to the
New Yorker Ron's strength as a
politician is that he doesn't give a
Ron's weakness as a politician is that
he doesn't give a
what do you think of that of that
depiction of where you've got to right
any truth to that I think like if you
look at the Daily News cycle all the
nonsense that gets the spaghetti that
gets thrown against the wall it doesn't
bother me at all I don't get get
involved with that like I have a true
north I have to get to on all the issues
that I'm trying to do either do it or
you don't and that will just kind of
take you off course and so in that sense
the political circus I don't care for
that and I don't I don't why but I do
think in terms of just every day waking
up I mean I care about making a
difference for people and you've seen it
like covet education all these things
people appreciate if you're willing to
stand up and fight for them man they'll
walk over broken glass Barefoot to
support you and that's what we've done
you've achieved a lot in Florida and you
had this thumping win one and a half
million more people voted for your
second time round it's Governor an
amazing validation of what you've been
doing and like I say I've been hearing
it firsthat so there's no denying you've
been very successful and very popular
but that prompts the question could you
do that nationally could you transport
the Rhonda santis
Playbook if you like for Florida and
make it work for the whole of America I
think you could I think one of the
things that was interesting about my
election is the voters in Florida
overwhelmingly thought the country was
on the wrong track but they thought
Florida was on the right track so they
saw the difference in terms of how
things are governed I mean just think
about it we run big budget surpluses
then Federal government's 31 trillion
dollars in debt were very tough on crime
uh the policies in Washington are to be
more weak on crime we believe in and
Stuart good stewards of the environment
but I don't want to control everyone's
Behavior with some of the stuff that's
going on and we have really fought
against the woke ideology you know
people this is not just
a whole book about it it's not just
Republicans they are concerned these are
across the Spectrum to have stuff that
that's being done people know this isn't
this isn't even in reality we cannot be
governed by a woke agenda and I would
tell you some of these Mayors and
prosecutors that have gotten elected in
around the country on that agenda you
know their societies have decayed as a
result of it San Francisco some of these
places where crime is up so I think just
some common sense some leadership some
courage and and being right on the
issues I think could go a long way what
I want to know is where did this come
from so tell me a little bit about your
upbringing I know your parents your
father was a Nielsen TV engineer for TV
rating because back then you had to put
the Box on the television sets and he
was physically doing that and your mum
was a nurse and they still live in
Dunedin I think in Dunedin Florida
founded by Scots yes indeed yeah
um tell me about them and about the
influence they've had on you so my
father was born is from Western
Pennsylvania in a town called Aliquippa
that's a steel Town his father worked in
the steel mills my mother's from
Youngstown Ohio another steel town so
this is Blue Collar gritty uh religious
patriotic and so I was born in Florida
and grew up in the in the Tampa Bay area
and and that was a great place to do but
in terms of like my household values
really reflected that working class
upbringing and basically what I think
instilled In Me Is You know I love the
country trusted God but just really
believed you don't get anything handed
to you in this life you've got to work
for it and so I had a work ethic that I
developed in my childhood and that
carried me through that you know there's
a lot of things that happen in this
world that you can't control the one
thing you can control are you going to
be able to look in the mirror every day
and say I'm getting the most out of my
god-given ability and that's what I try
to do the other question I'd do is look
in the mirror every day and think
am I about to do something my mother
will either like or dislike there you go
do you have that same absolutely guiding
principle absolutely so your mother very
important in terms of keeping you on the
street yeah I mean look just in terms of
like like growing up I knew what was
right and wrong that was instilled into
me and that's just something that that
carries with you all the way for the
rest of your life you did a press
conference this morning and you were
responding to the reports rumors of
Donald Trump potentially being indicted
to and you gave an interesting response
very sort of supportive of him in a way
by saying yeah you know I think what's
happening there is outrageous it's
political posturing by this deer and so
on in New York and they should be
focused on more important things but you
also repeated twice you didn't have any
knowledge of hush money being paid to
Pawn Stars
was I right to
feel that there was a slightly
sensorious tone to that that kind of
thing is just not anything you would
ever get involved with well I think it's
there's a lot of speculation about what
the underlying conduct is that is
purported to be it and yeah the reality
is that's just outside my wheelhouse I
mean that's just not something that I
can speak to so uh you know I hope it
doesn't come to where you end up seeing
this going forward I mean look if you
are a very strident prosecutor in this
guy's on the left and you're not
Prosecuting a lot of crimes Manhattan's
gotten less safe you're going to go
after somebody on the other side for
some novel offense uh that just does not
Inspire confidence and people see that
as weaponizing the justice system so so
I think it's fundamentally wrong to do
that and you know I just made it be
known but who you know we'll see maybe
it won't come to that I mean we haven't
seen anything firm yet does personal
conduct in any leader politically in
America does it matter
how you behave as a leader I mean I
think at the end of the day what a
leader you really want to look to people
like our founding fathers like what type
of character it's not saying that you
don't ever make a mistake in your
personal life but I think what type of
character are you bringing so somebody
who really set the standard is George
Washington because he always put the
Republic over his own personal interests
when we won the American Revolution
Washington surrendered his sword George
III said well if he surrendered there's
no intrude into private grief without
him we could have had King Pierce that's
right I know but George III said he's
the greatest man in the world if he
gives up power and so I think the
personal is more about how you handle
your public duties and and the kind of
character that you bring to that
endeavor how important is truth to you
we live in a world where people talk
about my truth as if somehow you can
create your own version of the truth to
me facts of facts the truth is what it
is it's the truth
people feel whether it's been in the US
or the UK with Boris Johnson they feel
like there's been a departure from truth
being an important factor of leadership
a hundred percent I mean look look truth
is essential we have to agree that
there's a certain reality to the world
we live in and if we can just create our
own facts then we're never going to be
able to agree on anything or never
really be able to do policy in a way
that makes sense and so yes it's not
your truth or my truth it's the truth
you're a captain of your uh middle
baseball team I think the Little League
World Series he went to which was a big
deal at the time right and you didn't
win it but and he came up against some
Californian pitcher who's pitching at a
scene that's right right or not
um what did that whole experience though
bring you as a young a young Ron
DeSantis well at that time Taiwan was
the PowerHouse they would win it most of
the time so we did the first day of
practice for All-Stars we wrote wwt on
the bills of our hat we want Taiwan so
you're talking about only four American
teams even make it to Williamsport and
so we set out to do it and we got there
and we didn't win the whole world series
but that told me you know uh these
little little town little town in
Florida can put their mind to this and
do it you know you can accomplish really
great things and that was really the
first thing that I had ever done in my
life that was outside of my little
provincial upbringing and so I think it
really helped me just be willing to
shoot for the stars you went to Yale and
Harvard
um it was described as a blue collar kid
from tamper among the Communist
millionaires you said you were the only
person to leave either of those places
more conservative than you started I
think so I mean you know I wasn't
political when I got there because where
I came from I didn't know if you're a
republican Democrat but definitely like
you know God country those basic things
when I got there you know you had a lot
of militant leftism one of Yale's mottos
is for God for country for Yale but you
get in the classroom no way I mean it
was very anti-religion particularly
Christianity and very anti-americanism
and really adopting a lot of the
left-wing mantras of the day and I kind
of rebelled against that because I'm
like wait a minute you know I'm proud to
be an American uh I wouldn't be here if
I if in any other country perhaps and so
this is something that that I rejected
and then by the time I got to Harvard I
was already set they weren't going to
change me it's what's extraordinary is
to watch the way campus campus sort of
ideology is gone I mean if it was bad
then it's immeasurably worse now there's
no Cardiology has got a grip not just in
America but in the UK and around the
world
what do we do about this I mean when
students are basically conditioned to
think that there's only one way of
thinking that to me is you're heading
toward a kind of totalitarianism it's
it's actually dangerous for society that
they're not challenged with other views
and it's not good for them because when
they get into the real world their
assumptions have never been questioned
you should want your assumptions
question a university is about pursuing
truth it's about rigor and academic
integrity and giving people the
foundation so they can think for
themselves and be citizens of the
Republic not to impose ideology in
Florida we're actually doing something
about it I just appointed a bunch of
conservative trustees to new College in
Sarasota they've re-categorized the
mission to being a classical liberal
arts university and we're working with
all of our state universities to ensure
that they're not imposing ideology
through the bureaucracy we want there to
be free speech on campus we want the
professors to come from a wide variety
of viewpoints you can't have every
Professor having the same leftist Dogma
in the class that's not good education
it doesn't serve the best interest of
the state there was one was one
professor in America I can't know where
he was but it was quite extraordinary he
for 25 years he'd done a lecture
all the time about the use of offensive
language and as part of the lecture he
would use offensive language to
illustrate what he was talking about
and that a bunch of very woke hyped up
students complained that he was using
offensive language and he got fired for
using offensive language in a lecture
about the dangers of using offensive
language and at that point I realized
the world had literally gone nuts well
so we when we did the new College thing
there were professors from all across
the country uh contacting some of our
new trustees saying how do I get down
there and these are not all right
Wingers a lot of them were Democrats but
they see this really hostile environment
it's a very intellectually impressive
environment and it's like you're walking
on eggshells that you could lose your
job by making like some verbal faux pas
that is not the road that we want to go
down and it's almost like some of the
worksters you will pay a bigger price by
offending wokism than if you commit like
serious crimes other than that how is
that something that makes any sense
right I mean I lost a job because I
disbelieved Meghan Markle there you go
with her claims of racism against the
royal family I said I don't believe it
so I had to leave my job but it was
completely insane when you think about
it now I'd be fired for believing it
that's true right that's true I mean
it's true
um I'll get you though my book beat
print you know his his book had come out
earlier number one and then when I
became I was higher than Prince Harry
we're all very grateful what do you make
of those two you have a view of them I
don't I mean you know I think that um I
really respected the queen I mean I
think she was uh really elegant and I
think her stoicism and I think it was
really good you know as the younger
Generations it's a little bit more mixed
I mean that's just the reality
are they annoying I think for some they
are I mean look I'm not involved in that
blue I just kind of focus on but I think
for some Americans they can be you had a
choice when you left at Harvard which
was to take big money and go into
relatively easier work I guess than what
you chose to do but instead you wanted
to serve in the Navy that's a big moment
for you that decision why did you decide
to do that a lot of that was you know in
the wake of 9 11 the world had changed
you know I was growing up in like the
90s in high school and then in college
graduated before 9 11. our country
didn't have a care in the world when
cold war was over there was prosperity
and people weren't even thinking of that
and then when the towers fell it just it
changed my outlook and I know we didn't
have a draft or any of that but I was
like look you know I should be willing
to to help out here and I'll have time
to do other things in my life and so so
we ended up volunteering we did the Navy
and at that time I didn't know what I
was in store for but I ended up doing a
lot of stuff around the country and
around the world including being in Iraq
and it was really really valuable
experience I mean when you when you wear
the cloth of your country that's
meaningful service and the people that
you meet along the way are great uh but
there's just a lot you know Jack Kennedy
said people can look back on their life
with a great deal of satisfaction and
say I served in the U.S Navy and I agree
with them where were you on honor them
you know I was um I think I had just
graduated college and was kind of not a
care in the world and all of a sudden
boom you know it happened and so I had
already been either accepted or planning
on going to law school and that's when I
decided to start looking into some other
other career choices that moment was a
pivotal moment in modern American
history in many ways Unleashed a whole
series of consequences
would you have done things any
differently if you've been running
America at the time obviously we're 20
years on from the Iraq War for example
which many viewed as an illegal conflict
potentially but certainly one that
created a lot of turmoil the rise of
Isis and so on would you have invaded
Iraq so I think in hindsight it's very
easy to make these things so clearly we
had to go to Afghanistan knock off the
Taliban and and decimate Al Qaeda I
would not have stayed in Afghanistan for
what we did I mean the idea that we were
going to turn that into a democracy it's
just a different culture and they're
they're organized differently and then I
think in Iraq what I saw there was you
know you said democracy when Saddam was
removed these are people cozying up with
the Iranians and so we now have a
situation where Iraq is basically an
Iranian satellite and Iran has probably
been our most significant adversary
certainly in that region you know since
the Shah fell so in hindsight I mean I I
honor everybody's service because I
think they get a lot of great things but
in hindsight has the Middle East gotten
better as a result of that I think
Iran's gotten stronger as a result of
that conflict you spent some time at
Guantanamo Bay obviously a very
contentious entity in many ways Barack
Obama campaigned in 0809 to close it and
didn't still open today
clearly a lot of very bad people went
there but we now know there were some
who were detained for over a decade and
were innocent people you were there in a
legal capacity did you have any qualms
about what was going on there about
holding people that long without trial
well I think that there should have been
military commissions I did support that
but what I saw because there was a
median there about they were being
mistreated in gitmo what I saw was
basically a professionally run prison
and there was different kind of
categories so the clean Shake Mohammed
is going to be in like a maximum
security some of these other guys were
like open air play soccer all day who
were viewed as less of a threat but what
they're trying to figure out is okay if
we release this person back to
Afghanistan are they going to engage in
terrorism against and that's hard to
know definitively so I think they tended
to err on the side of caution now I will
say these detainees would all say they
all said they're Koran salesman like
every one of them was a grand salesman
and that clearly wasn't the case either
but did you have any issues as a lawyer
with people being held that long with
well without any trouble but it's a
tough it's a tough thing when you have a
situation with terrorism and War because
they're not a nation-state and how they
they you can't try them I think in a
civilian court so you really need
military commissions I actually thought
I was going to be involved in military
commissions and they really just
sputtered they didn't get off the ground
they should have had those up and
running and it's some due process but it
isn't what you would get in a civilian
trial the Washington posted a big deep
dive on this today actually about what
you did out there one of the things they
said was that you authorize the use of
force-feeding that's some of the yeah
that's not true yeah any of the stuff
that people just have finished it Force
feeding the detainees who were on Hunger
Strike was that true so I was a I was a
junior officer I didn't have authority
to authorize anything there may have
been a commander that would have done
feeding if someone was going to die but
that was not something that I would have
even had authority to do so that's
that's wrong yeah absolutely
what did you learn you then went to
Fallujah in 2007 that was the year of
the search really more American troops
died that year than in any year in in
since World War II I think so really
incredibly dangerous and and a lot going
on you were there as a legal counsel to
the commander of sealed Navy SEAL Team
One and obviously the seals weren't as
well known as they are I guess now
um but incredibly demanding job I would
think under a lot of pressure what did
you learn about yourself while you were
doing that well it's interesting so you
know we had folks all across allium bar
Province so like the headquarters was
Fallujah we had ramadi al-assad haditha
hit all these places and there were
operations every night and you know they
tend to work at night and so you're
you're just crazy out one day after
another after another for a six six and
a half month period
um but you know at the end of the day I
mean honestly I kind of felt honored to
be there because these were some of our
best people uh that I was able to kind
of hitch a wagon with and they were
making a good difference by the time we
left there were not Americans dying in
alambar Province anymore I mean Al Qaeda
and Iraq had been crushed The anbar
Awakening had happened and most of the
deaths at that point probably 90 percent
were in the Shia areas with the Iranian
back forces so so it was a successful
deployment not just our deployment but
the Marines and the Army who were there
during that time did you come under any
personal attack not anything special I
mean you know I would travel from
different areas but what they would do
is like if you fly in a helicopter they
would do pitch black at night so that
they couldn't you know shoot it down
with an RPG but they would not go in the
daytime for transport because they were
concerned about that and then the other
risk was just being in convoys and um
you know they had done the IEDs at the
time and I never had any of that happen
to me thankfully still quite a an
unnerving experience well you just don't
know I mean because the thing is we
could defeat them on the battlefield
without even blinking an eye but that
wasn't how they were fighting they were
fighting to try to say if you're going
convoying from ramadi to Fallujah we're
going to try to blow up your convoy and
so it's just kind of like okay if the
numbers called the numbers called
I want to talk to you about another War
Ukraine uh I was quite surprised I'll be
honest with you by what you said last
week about Ukraine describing it as a
territorial dispute it's picked up a lot
of blowback as you know only surprised
because of your military background
because you were on record as supporting
helping Ukraine after the invasion of
Crimea
do you regret actually just using that
one phrase well I think that it's a
territorial distance I think it's been I
think it's been uh you know
mischaracterized obviously Russia
invaded that that was wrong they invaded
Crimea and took that in 2014. that was
wrong what I'm referring to is kind of
where the fighting is going on now which
is that western border or eastern border
region donbess and then Crimea and you
have a situation where Russia has had
that I don't think legitimately but
they've had there's a lot of ethnic
Russians there so that's some difficult
fighting and so whatever the conflict
area that's what I was referring to and
so it wasn't that I thought Russia had a
right to that and so if I should have
made that more clear I could have done
it but I think the larger point is okay
Russia has not shown the ability to to
take over Ukraine to to topple the
government or certainly to threat NATO
that's a good thing they've been
weakened you now have the fighting in
those areas I just don't think that's a
sufficient interest for us to escalate
more involvement I would not want to see
you know American troops involved there
but the idea that I think somehow Russia
was was justified and that's nonsense
and I was in Ukraine interviewing
president zolenski last summer what I
was struck by was the utter resolve of
the people there which I suspect would
be exactly the same as somebody invaded
any part of America which was not to
give Putin an inch not an inch in fact
they wanted Crimea back and I think they
would they would take issue with it
being categorized I think they have the
right to that territory I just think
that's the source of the conflict it's
in those regions which there's likely
going to continue to be a lot of
conflict on that going forward so if I
could Snap My Fingers I'd give it back
to Ukraine a hundred percent but the
reality is what is America's involvement
in terms of escalating with more weapons
and certainly ground troops I think
would be a mistake so that was the point
I was trying to make but Russia was
wrong to invade they were wrong to take
Crimea what's your view of Putin
look I think he's got Grand Ambitions I
think he's hostile to the United States
but I think the thing that we've seen is
he doesn't have the conventional
capability to realize his Ambitions and
so he's basically a gas station with a
bunch of nuclear weapons and so for us
one of the things we could be doing
better is utilizing our own energy
resources in the United States we could
be permitting natural gas pipelines from
Marcellus doing a lot in in Alaska
that's where he gets all his power and
obviously he's influenced Europe uh by
by having so much energy so the way to
hit Putin is to hit him with energy but
I do think you look back all the defense
analysts and me in the past we
overestimated his conventional
capability this has been a huge blunder
for him uh huge costs and uh you know
we'll see what ends up happening with
his longevity and and power but but this
has been a this has been a loss for them
there is a move now to hold him
accountable for war crimes bombing
maternity hospitals and genocidal
activity in parts of Ukraine it's wiping
out whole cities maripole and others
which you support that I mean I think he
is a war criminal this ICC we have not
done that in the United States because
we're concerned about our soldiers or
people being brought under it so I don't
know about that rubric but I do think
that that he should be held accountable
how does it end the Ukraine war do you
think that's the thing I mean I think
it's it's I think those regions and the
border and Crimea you know I think are
likely to uh to be a stalemate for quite
some time and you know unfortunately a
lot of people will end up dying if
that's the case but I do not think it's
going to end with Putin being Victorious
I do not think the Ukrainian government
is going to be toppled by him and I
think that's a good thing one of the
issues about it was well people were
saying okay well what happens if China
decides to invade Taiwan which may well
happen in the next couple of years if
they do is that also a a territorial
District so that yeah the the the the
thing territories just that's where the
fighting was you know there's not as
fighting on the on the on the western
side and you have situations where
there's ethnic Russians there and it's
just it's it's a it's a messy situation
but Russia did not have a right to go
into Crimea or to go in in February of
2022 and and that's that should be clear
and if China did invade Taiwan that
would be aggression absolutely it would
be aggressive Americans should get
involved in in that so I would say that
Taiwan is a is a strong Ally of the
United States
um I think that that's a critical
interest I think it's for us but also
for our key allies like Japan and South
Korea and I think overall the number one
issue that we Face internationally is
checking the the growth and the rise of
China they're much more powerful I think
than root than Putin in Russia are and
they really represent the biggest threat
that we've seen to to our ability to to
lead since the Soviet Union would you
buy tick tock I would I think so would
you I think so I mean I think from
everybody in America I think I think
it's a security risk I think they are
harvesting so much data uh on our
citizens there's a whole bunch of other
apps and stuff that are out there and
honestly Pierce I got young kids I don't
want our kids on some of this stuff it's
not healthy for you haven't seen the
cute dog tick tock I've seen that but
you know what the CCP does The Tick Tock
in in China is sanitized it's more
wholesome here they're putting in a lot
of bad stuff too so I think it's had a
corrosive impact but that in and of
itself wouldn't be enough what's enough
though is how they're harvesting that to
use against the American people you're a
father of three young kids I've got four
kids but they're all a bit older one's
11 now the other's in the 20s but social
media it seems to me to have been a real
double-edged sword a lot of great comes
out of it the ability to communicate and
everything else a lot of bad stuff too
is coming with it what do we do about
social media do you think well it's it's
really tough and when some of this I
think back when actually when I was in
Iraq I had to use a satellite phone to
call to call Casey I had no face time I
had no ability to do any of that it just
didn't exist then so now you have the
ability to connect with people I mean
there is some huge benefits but these
kids I think that they get mired into
this I think there's a lot of bad stuff
that go over there and what we try to do
with our kids they're six four and two
and we say like you need to be outside
playing around reading books and doing
all that so I think in terms of the
youth I think the social media has had a
net negative on that one of the things
I've proposed which some of these people
criticized me for in schools is you know
a teacher should have the right that
students should put their phones in the
front of the class sit there and learn
then they can grab the phone I agree
with this yeah I mean like why do you
want them on the phone I agree with most
of the things you're doing in school I
think it's because I've had four kids
you've gone through school yeah and
you're like why why wouldn't you
actually take their phones away yeah I
need phones and it's just you put them
in a cubby or something it's not like
the the school is going to like search
their phone you put it in the cubby sit
down do your lesson then take it if you
want to use it at recess or all that but
I definitely think more people that live
their lives on those apps and those
phones you know that's not good good for
society and on sex education in school
what is your clear position on that now
so what our our position is basically
you know we don't want to be injecting
sexuality and things like gender
ideology and particularly the younger
grades and you know you do have places
around this country where they will have
kindergarteners say Okay declare what
your gender is or tell a student that
they may have been born a boy but maybe
they're really a girl that is totally
inappropriate I think these are things
that parents should be taking the lead
on as they deem appropriate but that
should not be imposed in the in the
school system did you ever think you'd
be alive in a world where a six foot
four inch former male swimmer could
suddenly identify as female and start
demolishing women born to female bodies
in competitive swimming for example yeah
you know what I'm talking about pen it
just seems after spending three years on
the men's team unsuccessful and then
switching there and then you have the
situation you have that famous picture
of of the swimmer within the three women
and there are they're so much smaller
the runner-up on that was actually from
Sarasota and I did a proclamation from
the state saying she was the rightful
winner she was the best women's 500 yard
freestyle swimmer so it's taking away
opportunities from girls and women
athletes in Florida we basically said
look we're going to go based on biology
and we're just going to do that and
people can can can either like that or
not but we're not going to take away
opportunities from these young girls I
completely agree I think it's a mad
debate talking of of young girls
actually a young woman that you met on a
golf range many years ago see there you
are you're on a golf range and you spy
two things one is it was a bucket of
balls that you have and there's this
very beautiful woman
who didn't know but she was called Casey
turned out to be your wife yeah you
didn't know that now she tells this
story and says that actually she was
looking over an eyeing with great
covetousness your bucket of balls your
version is that she was looking at you
and eyeing you up have you reached an
agreement about this so I thought she
was looking at me I really did and yeah
we did have the balls and so I used the
balls as a way to start talking to her
but you know my view was like look I'm
what what's the worst she can do not
want to talk to me I'm like I am not
letting this opportunity go so we went
over there we started talking we divvied
up the balls hit him and then we went
out after that and kind of kind of the
rest is history but I think in fact she
was looking at the balls I do think I
was wrong but you know what so you have
a bunch of golf balls to thank for true
love you do and who would have thought
that we both would have been there at
the same time randomly on some random
day in 2006 you know I'm just a fresh
into the Navy and she's uh she was a
local TV reporter at the time and we
just happened to hit it off when did you
know this is the one for me I mean I
would say like pretty early I was like
this is different and um you know I made
sure to to court her course I got
mobilized to go to California then Iraq
so we stayed together through all that
but I told myself like as soon as I get
back from Iraq I'm popping the question
and so we ended up doing that and how
did you do that
oh I took her to a nice little Resort in
Florida and we kind of went out and we
were out on the balcony and just kind of
dropped to the knee and you just bended
knee oh yeah of course so you took the
knee Governor yeah yeah that's the only
time I'd take a knees for that one so
and she uh and you had a ring had a nice
ring and everything everything was
really good did she hesitate no no
immediately immediate yeah well I think
she you know she had let it be known
that that she was happy and that that we
were ready to go to the next level as
well so I don't think it was anything
that was like a super shock but um but
it was good to get that get that one in
the win column how many times would you
say
before that you'd been properly in love
oh I I don't I don't think anything like
this I think that this was definitely
unique for me
and it's been great ever since I don't
think I could have done any better in
life I mean I really don't
um not just to have a friend you know
she gets more beautiful as she gets
older and we have three wonderful kids
she's a great mother she's a great first
lady I mean she's really the whole
package and you know there's a picture
that I have 2019 inauguration 2023
sitting at the desk same pose she's
prettier in 23 than she was in 2019 and
she had a kid she went through four
years of this nonsense and she beat
breast cancer and how do you end up
being prettier after four years of that
she finds a way to do it when she got
cancer she told free moving about this
in a campaign commercial for when you
run for governor in 2022 but she taught
for a
emotionally about it and gave a real
like
heartfelt assessment of you and I don't
want to you know bring your blushes here
but she said
when I was diagnosed with cancer I was
facing the battle for my life he was the
dad who took care of my children when I
couldn't he was there to pick me off the
ground and I literally couldn't stand he
was at a fight for me when I didn't have
the strength to fight for myself
when you watch that because I don't
think you'd seen it before it went out
no and you see your wife crying as she
pays that kind of tribute to you what
did that make you feel well look you
know for sickness and in health good
times and bad I mean that that's the job
of a spouse and I I to have her thank me
publicly like that was was very
heartwarming I know it touched a lot of
people throughout the State of Florida
and you're right I didn't know what she
was going to say because she asked me I
want to go over this thing I said you
know don't worry about my filter don't
listen to anyone else you just speak
from your heart so she kicked everybody
out of the room when she when she filmed
it except the camera guy and she just
spoke from the heart no script know
anything and I think it told a lot of
people about kind of what we've gone
through as a family you know you never
want to see anyone go through something
like that but there is something a
little bit more poignant when you have a
young mother that's fighting for her
life with these young kids because no
none of these no kids should lose a
parent like that and so that I think was
a source of fight for her it was a
source of fight for me and we just had
such a great outpouring of support from
the community that it did lift her
spirits did you fear that you may lose
her so it's interesting you always have
that fear but I'm a data guy I went and
looked it up I said you're going to beat
it she's like and she didn't necessarily
want to hear that because she was so
scared just as anyone would be but I'm
like I've looked at the data I'm looking
at the treatments you know you're going
to be okay so I really felt confident
and we the doctors had a plan I talked
to doctors all around the country and I
didn't even tell them what the plan was
I was like okay what do you recommend
and they all said do the things that we
ended up doing so I felt really really
comfortable there was a big consensus
from people all over the country that I
talked to I knew it wouldn't be easy but
I absolutely thought she was going to
beat it what was the lowest moment do
you think I think the chemotherapy I
mean I think too I think the beginning
when we get the because she went to the
doctor she felt something the doctor
cleared her they did a a physical exam
said that you didn't have anything don't
worry and like me if a doctor said said
I'm okay I would never think twice about
it she had a feeling that there was just
something wrong so she really fought to
get a mammogram and so a couple weeks
later we got it I told her I was like
you're fine and then it came back and so
I think that was really really different
that's a jolt moment it really is
because it totally changes your life it
changes your family's trajectory
everything all of a sudden is up for
grab so I think that was you know one of
the most difficult and then just not
knowing what to expect especially before
we saw a physician and one of the cancer
doctors we had no idea really what we
were dealing with apart from my kind of
side research that I'm pulling up stuff
from like Mayo Clinic and researching so
then that was tough and then I would say
the chemotherapy it just it saps you I
mean it's just and actually each course
can get progressively and it's more
unpleasant right it's putting like
poison in your body and to see someone
that you love go through that you know
it was really tough on her but it's also
just you hate to see it's like what can
you do I mean I can't make it all of a
sudden get better so that's why I was
there just this being the helping hand
and so if I went to all the the
chemotherapies with her it was
interesting I got attacked by by the
left for not being in the office one day
because my schedule's put out every day
so there was one day where there was
nothing on the schedule and this was in
between like Christmas and New Year's
and like all a lot of these other
Governors are in the Caribbean
vacationing but I was so I met Moffett
Cancer Center with her when they were
saying that I wasn't doing my job and
you know I was just like politics it's
it's fine to do but it's like you know
you should definitely be rooting for the
first lady of our state to do well and
you should be thankful that her husband
is there supporting her when she was
declared cancer did she ring the bell
did she she did yeah yeah were you there
yeah absolutely I'm in that moment for
you oh yeah yeah well you know here's
the thing well I know you're a tough guy
Ron DeSantis I know standing there is
your wife Rings the cancer we had a big
hug and uh did you shed a tear that I
was I was emotional
um and you know we celebrated a little
bit afterwards which was uh which was
good but I I believe that that's what
was going to happen and so for me it was
confirmation once we got the scan
results and everything I knew that that
was the result she I think
still wasn't convinced that she was
cancer-free until they finally did all
the tests and the doctor told her you're
cancer-free how did you celebrate
actually Guinness did you really we both
really like Guinness I mean we're um
it's just something and when I remember
we we went to Ireland Scotland years ago
and like just being in the pubs being
able to do it it's you know they said
that the that the beer was um was all
warm over there but they actually have
Guinness extra cold Taps oh no so you'd
get it I mean it's just fantastic so you
had a couple of puns again that's right
no matter what it does
there was a incredibly sad time in your
life which was the loss of your sister
um Christina who died in London it was
reported she died of a pulmonary
embolism is that is that what happened
and she was leading a great life she
just got engaged I think to a British
guy her life was all ahead of her
and then Bang
it's all taken away and she dies at the
age of 30. what was that moment like for
you and your family well I think it was
just you know it kind of like a
shattering experience you know partially
because she was doing well she was very
happy she she was over there and I
remember my Mom calling me my wife and I
were on our way back from church it was
like a Sunday after Sunday morning and
she said that you know Christina's in
the hospital she had a blood clot and so
I'm thinking like is she okay and she
seemed to be stable so she was in the
hospital for a couple days and then had
the embolism uh and died in the hospital
and so I just didn't think that that was
something that was even possible at that
point because I thought that she was
stable and so we were I mean you just
feel like you know you have your sibling
you know their their future was robbed
and um you know it's just something I
wish I could get back call breaking yeah
really heartbreaking
because I think she would
you know she probably would have moved
back to Florida she was in Charlotte at
the time working for for a bank but she
always wanted to get back here and so
you know she would be she would be here
probably being involved in a lot of
stuff that we were doing and uh so
what did she make of of you and what was
happening with you
I was the big brother so we were 85 I
was seven years apart so we weren't
necessarily ever in like the same school
together any of that so I was kind of
like a little bit rarefied air in some
respects she always looked up to me
um and I think some of it was because I
was doing things she tried to measure up
to me and I told her I was like don't
worry about that I was like you just be
you and and do do what you can do and
you know she was very successful
um you know once she got out of school
she got her Masters and everything so
um but you know it just it's it's a it's
a tough thing you're clearly feeling
quite emotional thinking about it yeah
it's hard to think of a worse thing
actually for a family I think than
losing a sibling I mean I just think you
know people have their whole lives ahead
of them and when you're talking about
that age it's just it's a big tragedy
you're a Catholic I'm a Catholic
um how important is Faith at a moment
like that for you it's important because
I think you start to question
um you know
things that are unjust like why did this
have to happen and you just have to have
uh faith that that there's a there's a
plan in place you know trust in God
there's no guarantee that you're going
to have a life without challenges and
without heartbreak and that's just the
the function of Being Human and so so it
was important for me you pray I do every
day you try to do you yeah you take time
every day to try to I do what do you
pray for
I usually just praying for family I'm
praying for the health of the State uh
praying for wisdom when I when I need to
kind of tap into that
do you think you've got wisdom I try to
I mean I think that um that's something
that's accumulated with experience and I
think I've gained a lot since I've been
Governor but um you know I wouldn't say
that um that I'm tapped out yet I got
more to do
let's get to the question you're not
going to answer
you want to guess can't imagine
let me ask you anyway and you can you
can bat it away because I'm not
expecting to you to announce now but
everybody's assuming you're going to
announce reasonably sitting at a run for
president United States
are you so I haven't made a final
decision on it I've told people I've got
a lot that I've got to do over the next
few months in Florida we're going to put
a lot of points on the board and then
we'll see how the dust settles after
that but I can tell you we just have a
lot of people that realize the country
is not going in the right direction and
believe that what we've been able to do
in Florida if we could apply that
nationally would kind of get America
back on track and back on our
foundations and so I take that very
seriously it's humbling that people have
come to me and and asked me to do it or
urge me to do it so stay tuned
that sounds like almost a yes
it's a stay tuned I mean why wouldn't
you well because I mean look I I've got
a young family I mean I've got I've got
different different uh obligations and
it's not the easiest thing in the world
uh to to go through and I also want to
make sure that you know I have a very
clear rationale for doing what I'm doing
all I'm interested in doing is getting
things done and accomplishing things I
don't need a title I don't need Fanfare
I just want to know that if I put my
mind to this if we ever did that and
were successful what could I do to make
a difference and and that's what I have
to have do you think you have what it
takes to be president of the United
States look I think what it takes is to
have a vision for the country have the
ability to exercise leadership and being
willing to stand in that fire when it
gets really really hot and and not back
down under pressure and I think I have
all those things you go to Great
endorsement from someone Ron DeSantis is
a brilliant young leader then Harvard
Law who would make a great governor of
Florida which turned out to be true he
loves our country he's a true fighter
and there's a ringing endorsement from
president Trump
times change a little bit I guess you
know it is what it is yeah I mean he was
a big fan no I mean I think and I think
you know we had a good relationship as a
congressman and I think one of the
reasons he got to know me is because I
saw this Russia collusion thing as a
farce from the beginning very few people
said that we had a handful of us in
Congress that were fighting back against
that uh and so I would go on TV and I
would defend him uh when it wasn't
popular and when it was kind of
politically risky but I just thought it
was the right thing to do and I thought
that he had good ideas for the country
so I wanted to do and then when I became
Governor his last two years as president
I was governor my first two years and we
worked very well together I mean he he
had a place in Florida he wasn't a
resident yet but he understood Florida
and really worked well with us to to
serve our state you made a fatal error
in your relationship what's that Donald
Trump you got too popular
well I I would say if you look at some
of the the change from that and all the
way up what's been the kind of the major
thing that happened that's that's
changed this tune was my re-election
Victory I mean that's just that's kind
of the market well because many of his
picks in the midterms did badly and you
who had been you know he was a mentor in
many ways I guess early on had this
thumping Victory uh and I guess if
you're him and you're desperate to get
back to the White House this was a bit
of a nightmare that you were getting
such validation in Florida you know my
view though is like look we should want
the country to do well I want other
Republicans to do well I'm not I want
them to Eclipse me you know we're
setting a great standard in Florida
we'll have everyone up their game I want
other Governors to do to do a great job
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't think even he went off
meatball wrong I can't uh I don't know
how to spell the sanctimonious I don't
really know what it means but I you know
I kind of like it's long it's got a lot
of valve I mean so we'd go with that
that's fine you know you can call me you
can call me whatever you want I mean
just as long as you you know also call
me a winner because that's what we've
been able to do in Florida has put a lot
of points on the board and and really
take the state to the next level at some
stage I mean have you read
um Mary Shelley's book Frankenstein I
have not okay it's a great book and
obviously it's spawned several movies
but there are prophetic words of warning
from Dr Waldman to Dr Frankenstein you
have created a monster and it will
destroy you
and you're alluding for what I have seen
the movie though it is a good movie you
know what I'm talking about Governor
it's like when Dr Frankenstein creates a
monster then loses control of the
monster and in the book obviously the
monster ends up killing him well look at
the end you know the parallel I'm making
at the end of the day
um you know what's best for the country
and let's put the country first rather
than worry about any personalities or
any type of individual um you know the
end of the day I'm a vessel for the
aspirations of the people I represent
it's really not about me it's about
whether I can be someone and yes you
have attributes leadership some of the
things you mentioned thick skin I think
is important but ultimately it's about
them you know it's not about me and I
think of every elected official thought
that way you know we'd probably be
better Ronald Reagan said is no limit to
what you can accomplish if you don't
care who gets the credit
that's true but you're up against
somebody who definitely cares who gets
the credit who's desperate to want to
win back the White House and prove that
his theory that he had it wrong well I'm
not up against anybody you know quite
yet we're up well the polls the polls
please have you two yeah up here and
everybody else down here so if you do
the way the way I view it though but the
way I view it though if I were to to run
uh I'm running against Biden like we're
competing for the Republican potentially
I get that but ultimately you know the
guy I'm going to focus on is Biden
because I think he's I think he's failed
the country I think the country wants a
change I think they want a fresh start
and in a New Direction and so we'll be
very vocal about that I spent a lot of
time in Florida fighting back I think
you could beat bud I think so
so you're running them no I didn't say
that I just said I think I could I mean
I think that that's I mean if you look
at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout I don't
know those are two different differences
I mean if you do decide to run I mean
let's you know we can pretend around the
horses here but if you do decide to run
in the next few months obviously it will
then be UV Donald Trump for the
Republican nomination people have been
quite kind of scathing they've said
you're house trained Donald your diet
coke to his full Coke right you've heard
all this stuff
what are the differences between you
well I know what I know him very well
I'm having now spent time with you I
could immediately identify a few
differences but what do you think of the
differences well I mean I think there's
a few things I mean obviously you know
the approach to covid was different I
mean you know I would have fired
somebody like fauci uh I think that he
got way too big for his britches and I
think he did a lot of damage I also
think just in terms of my approach to
leadership you know I get Personnel in
the government who have the agenda of
the people and share our agenda if you
bring your own agenda in you're gone
we're just not going to have that so the
way we run the government I think is no
daily drama focus on the big picture and
put points on the board and I think that
that's something that's very important
you've not been sucked into responding
to any of the taunts is that a
deliberate strategy I'm just not
following it I mean I get taunted and I
get attacked every day I mean you see
some of that I it to me it's just kind
of background noise it's not important
for me to be fighting with people on
social social media it's not
accomplishing anything for the people I
represent so we really just focus on
knocking out victories day after day and
if I got involved in all the undertow I
would not be able to Be an Effective
Governor so I don't think it's something
that makes sense for me as always say
around maybe a presidential run gets
hotter a lot more Focus now on you and
policies and so on one of the things
that people criticize you about they say
you try to straddle various positions
here which are unsustainable going
forward one is to win the Republican
nomination and to appeal to the Trump
Naga base and the other would be to to
win a national election against Joe
Budden you know this and some of your
critics say that you're trying to Pander
too much to the right examples being
this bill going through to try and
reduce the abortion time limit to six
weeks in Florida which would make it one
of the toughest places in America to
have an abortion the bill also
potentially going through about the
ability to carry a gun in a concealed
way without a permit when you need a
permit for example to drive a car people
are saying that you're pushing this
really quiet I don't want to get into
the semantics of those of those debates
right I've learned that it's an American
issue and that debate should be had by
Americans and I respect that but in
terms of where you position yourself are
you worried that if you take such
Hardline positions hard conservative
positions on things like abortion guns
and so on that it makes it more
difficult for you to win a national
election should you choose to run well I
don't really think that they're
necessarily Hardline positions I mean
for example the the concealed carry
that's 25 States have that in the United
States and I think we could say my first
four years as Governor a lot of people
said the same criticism that somehow I
was only doing stuff for for right in
reality I mean we were doing things like
race teacher salaries we were doing
conservation we were doing things across
the board and I ended up winning a
record Victory I won independence by 18
percentage points and so that'll be the
same formula that we would take and
honestly forget about me I think anybody
should take a formula like that
nationally you can't win with just
Republicans you got to win with
Independence and you need to convince
some of these Democrats which I was able
to do in Florida because you know there
are people that are Democrats because
that's what their family were they're
not woke they don't like some of the
nonsense going on they want their
streets safe and they want quality
education so I think you appeal to
people across the Gambit
I just wanted to check your fingers for
a moment
because I've noticed they're very
slimmed down onto santis you've lost a
lot of weight recently
well we're you know at the end of the
day it's like New Year's resolution just
get back in the swing of things I have
the same thing I'm a vet I'm a athlete
and a military veteran and so as
Governor you can get caught up in a lot
of other stuff how much have you lost I
don't know I mean I don't I don't weigh
or anything like that made quite a lot I
mean I'm on a good regimen and we'll
keep it going and uh apparently no carbs
and no dessert so I think the sugar is
the biggest issue because like basically
if you do sugar your body Burns sugar if
you don't it burns fat and so if you're
working out and just eating halfway
decent I'm doing exactly the same thing
by the way since Christmas we're almost
together there you go you're probably
doing a bit better than me but I was
asking about your fingers because of
this I mean Scandal which broke last
week that you apparently were eating
chocolate pudding with three fingers now
where does was that Anonymous sources or
something very serious allegation in
fact I congratulated the journalist who
broke it on the new Watergate
but I have to put it to you Governor
have you ever eaten a chocolate pudding
with three fingers I don't remember ever
doing that I'm telling you maybe when I
was a kid but it's interesting you know
there's a lot of people when you're when
they go at you sometimes they have like
really good ammunition like you're a
crook you stood this you did that for me
they're talking about pudding like is
that really the best you got okay bring
it on but now you're not having puddings
I don't know maybe they're sugar-free
pudding I gotta look into that and try
to figure out uh how we go from there
Governor it's been great to meet you
yeah and to get under the skin a bit of
Governor Ron DeSantis
um who knows next few months maybe we'll
come and interview again when you're
running for president I'm glad you came
to Tallahassee I know it's your first
time and uh we welcome you to Florida's
uh historic Capital next time you're in
St Andrews in Scotland we got to do that
let's have a little I can get out there
we got to do that a little battle on the
old course yeah that'd be like that'd be
England v America by the best man you've
got local knowledge I've only played it
once paid back for Jules the third there
you go good to meet you hey thank you
appreciate you appreciate your time
[Music]
thank you